- [Narrator] It's September, 1993.
And it's finally the weekend.
- Yay!
- [Woman] That's right.
(dreamy music)
♪ Ah ♪
- [Narrator] Movie tickets only cost
four dollars and 14 cents.
Frasier--
- I'm listening.
- [Narrator] Just premiered on NBC,
and women were finally
allowed to wear pantsuits
on the Senate floor.
(bell dings)
It's Saturday morning,
and that means one thing.
♪ And they're zany ♪
- Cartoons.
♪ The show ♪
- [Narrator] So at eight a.m.,
"Animaniacs" was on Fox Kids,
and we scheduled a
meeting with Rob Paulsen,
the guy who voiced Yakko.
- Oh, sure. (clears throat)
Okay, well let's see, I'm
Yakko Warner; hello, nurse.
- [Narrator] We wanna know about
the "Nations of the World" song.
- [Rob] Well, the interesting
thing is that it only took me
one take to record it.
- [Narrator] What?
♪ United States, Canada, Mexico, Panama ♪
♪ Haiti, Jamaica, Peru ♪
♪ Republic Dominican, Cuba, Caribbean ♪
♪ Greenland, El Salvador too ♪
♪ The art project ♪
- [Narrator] For most of
us, Perler beads got left
in the 1990s alongside
HitClips and Oakley Minutes.
- [Man] Cool.
(phone beeping)
- [Narrator] Hello, can you hear me?
- Loud and clear.
- Perfect.
Kyle is an artist, but
rather than paint or pen,
he uses Perler beads, even today.
- [Kyle] I am all-Perler, all the time.
Perler beads were invented by
a Swedish man in the 1960s.
It was originally a therapy
material for older folks.
- [Narrator] Kyle sees your
'90s Perler bead posters
and raises you this.
- [Kyle] I would say, without a doubt,
my most ambitious project has
got to be Project Springfield,
which is 40-square-foot mural
of the Simpsons' hometown.
It's over 140,000
individually placed beads.
And it took me about two years.
- [Narrator] It's your
nostalgia, only elevated.
♪ The birthday parties ♪
- [Kids] Happy birthday!
- [Narrator] The holy trinity
of the '90s kids'
birthday party was simple.
Pizza, cake, and laser tag.
(noisemaker toots)
- [Kids] Pew pew, pew pew!
- [Narrator] Amen; so we talked
to the man responsible for all of that.
- Hi, I'm George Carter,
I invented laser tag
about 30 years ago.
- [Narrator] The game was
inspired by a pretty famous movie.
- [George] The movie "Star Wars."
I had watched them going up
and down the halls of the ship
shooting lasers at one another.
And I thought I'd put it
in some sort of context
and make rules, and we
got a great game then.
It was more competitive
back in the early days.
Well, laser tag today has moved
into family entertainment centers,
with actually more people
playing than ever before.
- [Narrator] And there
it is, your weekend,
and some of the people behind it, 1993.
♪ All the cats ♪
- [Kids] Yay!
(light music)